hello everybody hope that you are good
yesterday was a bloody Monday that was a
a massive move down uh perhaps Monday's
false move at this that's what I think
and that what I've been expecting since
Sunday perhaps not as low as we went
yesterday to be honest with you because
we had a target of 62,500 because we saw
some liquidations there also the range
lows but it's true that we had a pretty
sharp deviation there now the current
structure is a range we've been playing
in this range for 3 months and a half
already perhaps your your range Highs
are here and your range lows are here in
my opinion these are not the range lows
but it's a strong support is not the
range lows because the range lows comes
after the first high so uh first we took
the high and then the drop so these are
the range lows in my opinion and this
cannot be the range lows because this
low happened before the first high so it
doesn't make much sense that us um the
range lows but it's true that is a
strong support so fair
dutes this I would say that between
these two lines it's a very strong
support you can say it and yesterday
that got proofed again so I'm going to
explain in this video what my theory is
uh what I'm up to because I'm already in
a position I'm in a trade so I want to
be transparent with you as always and
I'm going to tell you what I've done
what my game plan is um what I'm taking
profits what I'm leaving the trade uh
basically as I usually do trying to be
as transparent with you as possible but
of course it's not Financial advice
because maybe this video proves in a
couple of days that I've been wrong okay
so uh be careful and do your own
research and let me remove these lines
so we don't get
confused okay you can see that right now
if you go into the 4our time frame for a
more well 1 hour time frame let's go
lower time frame you can see that right
now we are above the range lows again
and to be honest as long as we're above
the range lows I'm happy to open Longs
because we've been playing this kind of
ping pong between the range highs and
range loans for quite long time three
and a three and a half months so who
knows maybe we go to the range highs
again all right but I'm not going to get
that far because I'm a day trader so I'm
going to tell you what my game plan is
with my current position okay the first
thing is the theory my theory tells me
that since Sunday that it was likely to
see on this false move a drop to the
downside it's true that that drop was
sharper than I originally thought but
that can still happen that's mon this
false move it's just a big drop and that
it happened so aggressively and so fast
it's even a a stronger sign that it's a
false move because false moves happen
very quickly and very aggressively so to
me I'm still going with the theory of a
Monday false move now if that was a m
false move then what's the real move the
real move is in the opposite direction
ction it's a short squeeze it doesn't
mean that going have got higher than the
when we were on Sunday it means that the
idea was to continue dropping so then
they can do a shorter squeeze more
efficiently okay and with that what I
mean is that yesterday what I've been
doing is I waited for New York to open
New York open here and I decided to open
along then at the range lows now that
trade the
entry I don't think it was bad but it
was also not good because you can see
the price continued dropping low lower
so I thought okay maybe we print a
deviation and I saw price was at um I
think it was
88,9 something like that around about
59,000 and I added to my position when I
open the trade here originally I thought
okay it's a possibility that we deviate
a bit lower because price been dropping
so who knows maybe drops a b more okay
and with the8 so right now my average
entry it's
exactly here
59,800 okay that's my average entry so
let me remove this here the second entry
that I took by the way that it was the
entry here it was basically on intuition
that price has been dropping for quite
long time and I think it's time to
bounce okay that's the deviation okay
time to bounce so that was not much on
technical analysis but more in
this entry here was more technical
analysis but it wasn't that good so at
the end my average entry is here
59,800 I'm right now in a profit and I'm
not closing a position just yet now I'm
going to tell you what I'm going to take
profits If he if he plays out and when I
would invalidate this trade close the
position at a profit by smaller profit
and then try to open a trade again in a
lower price so first of all why is
my take profits well my take profits
would
be if you notice
here okay let me change the color to
this line so we don't get confused
yellow is good we have here in the 15
minutes time frame this a strong
resistance now when we have a strong
resistance like this out of the
no it usually creates a lot of liquidity
above here and if you notice we have
here this High wow that's not a straight
line at all let me try
again kind of okay we have this High
there so that's going to be my Target
and also you have here some liquidity
pools getting a smaller but you can see
for example this liquidity pool here
it's quite a big one okay that Tak you
to 62,000 but I do believe that we can
get to 63,000 at least as a short
squeeze from 58,7 okay
so the way that I'm playing this is that
my take profits is around here in this
Zone well more like here in this Zone
okay that's my take profits so right now
I'm just pacing the waiting here what
happens I suspect that the most likely
thing is that we do something like this
maybe we can do a bit of a
flip resistance to support and then the
the leg up here okay to my take profits
that is what ideally want to happen and
that's what I'm playing with we're going
to go to High block capital in a moment
check what the liquidity is but I
imagine that we have a lot of
liquidations to the upside okay so that
would match with my theory but we're
going to have a look at that too that's
my take profits of this trade originally
from here now if we
lose the range
lows to the one time frame if we Lo if
we lose the range lows then you're want
to notice using the indicator
that we have here a weak okay so if we
do something like this at the end we
drop we're here we're consolidating a
bit then I close my trade from here I
take a bit of profits from this price
difference here it won't be much but
well as much as now but I would take the
profits and then I would open more
orders here of the 50% and the 100% of
the week however I see this less likely
because
usually after a deviation like this hang
on let's do do something like
this after a deviation like this below
the range lows then you usually see a
retest of the range lows and
continuation so I believe that we are
right now in that retest here okay
that's why we have this yellow line as
resistance we are building the liquidity
to the upsite at the moment okay so I do
believe that we're in that phase of
retest and continuation that's what my
idea is again maybe we check tomorrow in
tomorrow's video and this idea didn't
play out and it's wrong okay but that's
how my entry uh was thought that's how
my take profit is thought also look at
this guys we're in the one hour time
frame we had a target of 63,000 well
right below it but if you notice here we
have a liquidity pool let me zoom in a
bit we have a liquidity pool
also there at 62,700
so imag okay we have a liquidity pool
there of course we're going to have a
bit of issues with the 50 ma but that's
what my take profits would be okay now
let's go to h capital because I don't
want to make the video longer than than
I want so let's go there very
quickly High Capital liquidation levels
first of all pay attention to the Delta
the Delta yesterday when I made the
video was around 11 11 10 billion take
this with a pinch of Sal cuz I'm using
the max liquidity setting but we went as
low as 25 I think it was 24 billion okay
usually between 25 and 35 that's when
reversal usually happen according to my
experience okay so yeah 24 billion and
reversal happens there boom still we
have the Delta is 16 billion is s High
that means that there is a lot of
liquidity to to take to the upside and
these spikes at the right of the chart
they Pro that look at this spikes there
are a lot of spikes to the upside and we
have some even higher targets than the
chart we have here
64,800 and 66,000 these are the targets
that we pay attention to yesterday but
we have a big cluster of liquidations
especially in this Z here okay so you
can see these bubbles here get quite big
,400 another one here 63,800
another one here 62,200 so I believe
that the shortest squeeze is at least
going to take this area here all right
and now you can see that that matches
when I take profit so yes I'm paying I'm
putting money into this idea of a short
squeeze perhaps again it doesn't play
out but it's a game of probabilities so
nobody knows what is going to happen now
in the liquidation on hit map 7 Days
time frame you can see how we've taken
the liquidity to the downside and now
the liquidity is gathering to the upside
even all the way to 67,000 so that would
be a very strong sort of squeeze because
they're difficult to measure it can be I
I think what we've just seen is I
wouldn't consider this a short squeeze
at all H I would I would say that a
short squeeze would at least be from the
8,000 area to 63 ,000 that's at least
the area but it can go as high as
67,000 64,000 okay so um I do believe
that the liquidity now is going to be to
the upside at least for the next two
three days let's check the one month
time frame in the one month time frame
nothing really interesting no no nothing
really interesting cuz I see liquidity
at 55k
72,000 the distance are very high so so
um that's pretty much everything guys I
don't know what you think be careful
trading this week cuz you've seen
yesterday how the price behaved and uh
you have to be very careful with your
triggers with your invalidations to not
stick into a losing trade for too long
but um also I think the most important
thing is that when you are thinking
about entering the market then you think
okay what about if this other thing
happens and I'm and price goes a belowa
below my entry uh would my trade be inv
validated there or can it be a deviation
can it be these other support test so
when you think about those scenarios
then you understand more the risk
management that you need to use and
maybe you don't go all in with 100% of
the position maybe you just go with 30
40 50% and leave some cash for a lower
entry okay that's what I usually do and
and it works pretty well so anyway guys
I don't want to talk more much more
about it I'll update you also through X
and also if you want to access to the
indicator then uh what day is today
today is the 25th so in 5 days we are
giving access to a students from the
course there is a course available for
the 1st of July my website it's in the
description and also we're giving access
to active Traders using my b x referral
link so you have also the link in the
description and they're also giving a a
bonus campaign that giving up to $130
for registering to give you 30 for
trading a bit of trading volum they give
you another
$50 and for kyc that is optional it's
not compulsory they give you another $50
so um if you're interested in getting
the indicator then you know what youve
got to do thank you so much for watching
guys and I'll see you soon